il ya me semble-t-il une différence
entre une boutique dont 80% à 90% des
produits sont à mon sens interdit et un
bureau de tabac où il y a à peine moins
d'un pour cent des produits qui sont
interdits et d'ailleurs ces produits qui
ne sont plus qu'ils ne sont plus en
vente il ya une différence
ce qui me paraît très important par
contre c'est de bien rappeler la
législation pour que tout le monde soit
au clair et sache précisément si je
parle des buralistes s'ils vendent des
produits qui sont interdits ils ont ils
risquent des ennuis parce que en
fonction des circonstances je pourrais
peut-être être amenés à les poursuivre
et s'ils sont poursuivis et condamnés
ils vont perdre leur licence 2 de
bureaux de tabac donc des conséquences
importantes
et en ce qui concerne des boutiques de
ventre spécialisés il me semble aussi
important que les gens ne fassent pas
des investissements importants en termes
d'argent pour ouvrir des boutiques dont
on sait que elles vont à 90% ou à 80%
vendre des produits qui sont des
produits interdits et donc qu'ils vont
faire l'objet d'une fermeture
en france le principe c'est la liberté
du commerce et donc on a le droit
d'ouvrir une boutique à condition qu'on
ne fasse pas de choses illicites et donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
boutiques ont couvertes et dès leur
ouverture il y a eu des contrôles les
personnes qui veulent vendre doit
doivent être des produits estampillés
celles aidées doivent savoir que ils ne
peuvent en aucun cas vendre des fleurs
des feuilles et qu' ils doivent être
absolument certain que les produits
qu'il vend tu ne comptes contiennent pas
de trace de thc